estas son las imágenes reveladas por las
autoridades turcas de los cazas griegos
que se encontraban en un punto que de
acuerdo con ankara es zona económica
exclusiva turca
y las fuerzas aéreas turcas detectaron
mediante radar que seis cazas f-16
habían despegado de la isla de creta y
se dirigieron hacia la zona
grecochipriota los aviones trucos
identificaron a las aeronaves como
pertenecientes a grecia y los alejaron
de la zona
el episodio se presenta cuando continúan
las tensiones entre turquía y grecia por
el dominio del mediterráneo oriental y
sus recursos energéticos algo que ha
causado incomodidad y preocupación entre
los países de la unión europea pues la
zona ha sido el lugar de una intensa
actividad militar durante el verano este
viernes precisamente finalizaron las
operaciones militares que desarrollaban
grecia francia italia y chipre en
respuesta a las que también llevó a cabo
turquía
turquía cuenta con 38 barcos de combate
en el mediterráneo mientras que francia
grecia italia suman 90 turquía y grecia
son integrantes de la organización del
tratado del atlántico norte otan pero
rivales históricos la unión europea
anunció que podría sancionar ankara si
no hay progresos en el conflicto actual
we can pastún
podemos llegar a aplicar sanciones por
participación en actividades que
consideramos ilegales estamos firmes y
determinados para proteger los intereses
de la unión europea en solidaridad con
grecia y chipre turquía debe abstenerse
de realizar acciones unilaterales porque
gestión stein informe unilateral actions
las tensiones existentes durante años se
exacerbaron luego de que grecia y egipto
firmaron un tratado estableciendo una
zona económica exclusiva que interfiere
con la zona económica exclusiva que
reclaman turquía y libia y donde se
encuentran importantes yacimientos
gasíferos